live bild der mann der woche er ist
vizekanzler er ist bundesfinanzminister
und jetzt hat sich die spd-spitze
überlegt dass sie mit ihm als kanzler
kandidat auch nach 15 jahren mal wieder
ins kanzleramt ziehen möchte im nächsten
jahr dann olaf scholz heute abend bei
uns erstellt sich unseren und ihren
fragen zu hause genommen
beginnen wollen wir herr scholz mit dem
thema mallorca alle macht wieder
probleme ist wieder zum risikogebiet
erklärt worden was sagen sie all denen
die trotzdem noch nach halle aufbrechen
jetzt die trotzdem viel
jeder muss wissen dass das konsequenzen
hat für das was dann passiert wir haben
eine test strategie vereinbart wir haben
regeln und erwartungen hinblick auf
selbst quarantäne gewissermaßen
hinterher wenn probleme auftreten
und ich glaube dass muss auch jeder
genau wissen denn wir sind ja noch lange
nicht durch ich hab mal gesprochen von
einer neuen normalität und damit wollte
ich darauf hinweisen dass wir selbst
wenn die situation erstmal in den griff
kriegen wie das jahr passiert ist es
trotzdem ganz lange so bleiben wird dass
wir auf ganz plötzlich ausbreitung des
virus reagieren müssen es ist unter uns
nicht nur in diesem land sondern in
vielen ländern europas und der welt und
solange wir keine therapien und keine
impfstoffe haben wenn sie bei allen
angelangt sind wird das so bleiben das
ist plötzlich was neues hier finden sie
das ok finden sie das leichtsinnig
andere sagen unverantwortlich oder
finden sie selbstverständlich dass wir
jetzt gebucht hat das man halt auch
fliegt es sind ja konsequenzen damit
verbunden und sicherlich wird das auch
in dem einen oder anderen fall
schwieriger fallen weil natürlich manche
reiseveranstalter daraus auch
konsequenzen ziehen und es gibt
natürlich auch konsequenzen die man
genau bedenken muss für hinterher denn
es kann ja sein dass man nicht so
pünktlich zur arbeit kommt wie man sich
das vorgenommen hat und deshalb sage ich
nur allen denkt sorgt für dich darüber
nach das ist eine große verantwortung
die man hat und wir müssen alle
miteinander auf uns aufpassen und unsere
gesundheit schützen das hat mir sorgen
machen wie würden sie denn machen sie
freuen sich auf den urlaub dann
irgendwann im märz ist klar mensch das
könnte eng werden
warten sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen
art mit dem buchen und dann sieht es
doch richtung sommer wieder besser aus
und dann wird auch die regierung dafür
können fliegen aber haltet ein bisschen
abstand im urlaub und die spanier wir
haben kommt noch zu uns auf mallorca
wird geworben und dann buchen sie und
dann ein paar wochen später plötzlich
wird wieder dicht gemacht wie würden sie
es jetzt mach wir haben ja das alles
schon hinter uns und viele gebuchte
reisen sind ausgefallen in der
vergangenheit und ich glaube das werden
wir uns alle ganz klar machen müssen
dass kann von jetzt an in diesem und dem
nächsten jahr immer mal wieder passieren
es gibt da keine sicherheit das ist die
konsequenz des virus und ich persönlich
würde jetzt an dieser situation sagen
dass es mir ein zu großes risiko
also selbst wenn sie jetzt gebucht
hätten weil die regierung und vor allen
dingen auch die spanische regierung
gesagt der mensch kommt doch zu uns so
war die situation vor einigen wochen
dann ja das ist zu hause bleiben das ist
die lage in der wir uns befinden dass
niemand jetzt sagen kann das wird im
oktober sein das wird im april des
nächsten jahres sein das wird im juni
seien es hängt von ganz vielen dingen ab
die wir nicht alleine beeinflussen
können das einzige was wir beeinflussen
können ist dass wir nicht zögern und
sofort handeln so wie das jetzt passiert
und war das von ihnen leichtsinnig die
ganzen reisen wieder zu gestatten man
wusste ja dass die sommerferien kommen
man wusste auch dass die deutschen gerne
reisen dass nicht alle an der ostsee
oder an der nordsee bleiben dort an den
vollen stränden sondern das natürlich
viele soweit wieder möglich ist nach
mallorca wollen weil das leichtsinnig
das zuzulassen ein dass es sorgfältig
beraten worden
übrigens in deutschland viel intensiver
als in vielen anderen ländern
wir haben ja nun mal ein gut
funktionierendes föderales system da
werden alle bundesländer die für viele
dieser entscheidung auch unmittelbar
verantwortlich sind mit und die
bundesregierung und ich glaube das hat
auch dazu geführt dass wir gut
abgewogene entscheidung getroffen haben
in diesem fall ja auch noch verabredet
in ganz europa aber mit der entscheidung
ist immer verbunden dass wir sagen es
kann plötzlich anders werden wir werden
auf eine plötzliche ausbreitung des
infektionsgeschehen es sofort reagieren
aber wer hat das jetzt versammelt also
ich habe schon gesagt die regierung
hatte ja zeit lang für die reisen dann
wieder geworden sind sie schuld dass
jetzt wieder alles zurückgedreht werden
muss sind die deutschen urlauber schuld
die der party gemacht haben auf mallorca
oder sind die spanier schuld weil die
nicht genügend auf
die einhaltung der regeln geachtet haben
weil wenn man es gewusst hätte dass man
vier wochen später oder sechs wochen
später wie das rad zurückdrehen würde
hätte man noch nie aufgemacht wenn man
was gewusst hätte und deshalb finde ich
sollte man auch nicht immer gleich sagen
wer hat das versammelt sondern wir
müssen uns klar machen solange das virus
unter uns ist solange wir keine
therapien und keine impfstoffe haben
werden wir immer wieder solche situation
erleben aber es ist auch ein aufruf an
alle es nicht zu übertreiben denn die
party bilder die wir gesehen haben an
einigen besonders beliebten orten auf
mallorca waren sicherlich kein beweis
dafür dass alle genau verstanden haben
die sache ist wirklich riskant
also bisher haben dies schon versammelt
ich will das nicht sagen dass ich mit
dem finger auf irgendjemanden eingeweiht
ich glaube das hilft dir überhaupt nicht
weiter wir werden uns darüber klar sein
müssen dass die sache noch nicht
ausgestanden das jetzt diejenigen die
aus diesem risikogebiet unter anderem in
mallorca zurück kommen die müssen sich
jetzt testen lassen in deutschland was
ist mit denen sollen die die tests
bezahlen müssen ihrer meinung nach oder
übernimmt das großzügig der steuerzahler
also wir haben ja eine regelung
getroffen dass es die möglichkeit gibt
zum beispiel den flughäfen kostenlose
tests durchzuführen
das ist abgewogen worden natürlich
könnte man gut sagen und sagen ja auch
einige durchaus mit vertretbaren
argumenten da ist ja die ausgangs
handlung dass jemand in urlaub gefahren
das dann kann er ja das vielleicht auch
noch machen aber das wichtigste sollte
und sagen dass wir eine möglichst große
zahl von reisenden haben die sich auch
testen lassen das muss die oberste
priorität haben deshalb finde ich die
entscheidung die wir getroffen haben
auch richtig also das bleibt dabei der
steuerzahler zeit jetzt selbst wenn
schon klar in der wird es wohl so sein
das ist gerade noch eine zwischenstufe
aber es ist klar ja also selbst wenn ich
jetzt noch aufbrechen wo ich schon weiß
risikogebiet ist mallorca ich flieg
dahin muss mich auf jeden fall testen
lassen dann zahlen die daheimgeblieben
vernünftig im auge fehler sind die
vernünftig sind zu hause bleiben die
zahl der jetzt in dieser situation immer
darüber nachdenkt dass man es irgendwie
im heim zahlen muss der glaube ich dir
verantwortung nicht gerecht die man
jetzt nicht einzahlen nur verantwortung
übernehmen für das was man macht also
wenn man ich glaube es wird
alles kein problem wenn man das so
machen würde aber das wichtigste ist
dass es möglichst viele tun und das
sollte punkt eins unserer
prioritätenliste sein
der gesundheitsminister sagt partyurlaub
ist unverantwortlich party urlaub also
party im ausland aber party zu hause
auch unverantwortlich dafür gibt es ja
regeln die die bundesländer überall
getroffen haben
und wer sich an diese regeln hält auch
bei den feiern im familiären bereich und
anderswo der reduziert ja auch die
gefahr einer größeren infektion
klar ist dass man wenn es dann doch dazu
gekommen ist möglich schnell bescheid
sagt und dass man auch hilft dass man
sofort gesagt und herausgefunden werden
kann werber alles dabei
denn das bleibt für ganz lange zeit
unsere allererste priorität dass wir
sofort herausfinden wer infiziert sein
könnte dass wir das daher sind und damit
eine ausbreitung des infektionsgeschehen
verhindern
sind sie zufrieden damit wie das in
deutschland bisher durchgesetzt wird
also wenn es versammlungen gab und
einige wollen sich eben nicht anders
masten gebot halten das dann wirklich
kontrolliert wird und nicht nur
kontrolliert wird sondern dass
anschließend bußgelder verhängt werden
sind sie zufrieden im moment damit wie
das durchgesetzt wird wie am vergangene
woche mal versucht herauszufinden wie
oft diese bußgelder bisher verhängt
worden
das befindet sich im moment im hunderter
bereichen ganz deutschland also es wird
kaum ein bußgeld verhängt sind sie damit
zufrieden
ja ich habe auch berichte über viele
bußgelder die erhoben werden für die
verschiedensten dinge die im
zusammenhang mit corona angefallen sind
gelesen da werden wir glaube ich an der
endgültige statistik er später bekommen
ich will ausdrücklich sagen es muss
bußgelder geben wenn gegen vorschriften
die wir miteinander erlassen haben
verstoßen wird das ist wichtig dass das
auch jeder dadurch versteht dass das
ganz ernst gemeint ist und deshalb die
allermeisten ist ja befolgen wir müssen
ja jetzt nicht so tun als ob die meisten
bürger in diesem lande sich nicht an die
regeln halten auch nicht als das
natürlich ein gewaltiger konfliktstoff
dimas gelder verwaltet ein bisschen da
das land fahren sie mal hier s bahn in
berlin
wenn sie
auf der ringbahn hört zu sagen und
wissen sie ganz genau dass an vielen
haltestellen ganz bewusst auch die maske
eben nicht getragen wird auch
möglicherweise um zu provozieren
was machen sie da wenn sie würden sie
dann machen wenn sie in die s bahn
einsteigen sie stören so ein fehler ein
und da sitzen drei und ihr weise füße
hoch auf den sitzen und haben keine
maske ganz bewusst was sagen sie denen
das jetzt kann er das durch ja ich
glaube schon dass das stück für stück
der fall sein wird das muss auch sein
und ihre fragen mache deutlich dass da
noch viele aufgaben vor uns stehen
ich finde aber auch dass wir zum
beispiel bei diesem etwas absurden
demonstrationen die wir gegenwärtig
beobachten auch darauf vertrauen müssen
dass die polizei gut abgewogene
entscheidung trifft denn das ist ja
immer eine insgesamt schwierige
situation und ich finde wer ohne abstand
da im großen umfang in solchen
demonstrationen mit macht ohne dass
irgendwelche sicherheitsmaßnahmen
beachtet werden ohne dass massen
getragen mit der gefährdet ja nicht nur
sich sondern auch alle anderen und das
ist doch das eigentliche was wir in
dieser corona krise gelernt haben wir
hängen alle miteinander zusammen die
idee dass man so ganz allein auf der
welt wird die ist jetzt vielleicht auch
mal verschwunden wir brauchen schon ein
solidarisches miteinander sonst für das
höhere bußgelder
das sind die entscheidungen die vor ort
getroffen worden sind von den ländern
und das wird es sicherlich noch mal die
eine oder andere erhöhung geben aber es
sind erst mal bußgelder festgesetzt
worden und das ist ein richtiger weg
mal startet die fußball-bundesliga
wieder und auch diese frage spaltet
deutschland ein wenig ja jetzt mit fans
oder ohne fans wie sie ihre auffassung
volle stadien wieder das glaube ich ist
im augenblick nicht drin
das ist mein geführten und das als sie
sind dagegen dass abend auch jeder dass
das sehr schwierig ist wir werden das
diskutieren mit den ländern das müssen
die gesundheitsbehörden ihre meinung
dazu entwickeln
aber wir können ja nicht in diese
sendung hinein uns diskutieren und reden
über neue risikogebiete und so tun als
wäre nichts los
also wer das gefühl hat die sache sei
abgehakt wir haben schon alles geschafft
der irrt sich und er macht einen
schweren fehler also deswegen den mit
aus der sinn und sie sind stand jetzt
sowie die lage jetzt ist die korona lage
dagegen die stadien wieder zurückhaltend
wer den zeitpunkt eine entscheidung die
ich nicht richtig nachvollziehen kann
weil wir die sicherheit gar nicht
gewährleisten kann
wir merken es ja gerade und sie stellen
wir lauter fragen dazu ja und das geht
auch weiter so und sie sind dann
vermutlich spricht jetzt ihre logik auch
nicht dafür in düsseldorf ein großes
konzert ausrechnen zu lassen auch wenn
sie nicht der veranstalter sind und das
nicht entscheiden müssen vor ort aber
vermutlich entspricht auch dass nicht
jeder logik 13.000 bei sarah connor und
kohlen düsseldorf da habe ich noch nicht
verstanden wenn ich das mal ganz höflich
sagen will
die ganzen sicherheitsvorschriften die
wir haben dabei eingehalten werden
können und deshalb glaube ich wird das
auch bei der beurteilung einer rolle
spielen müssen sie sind ja zuständig die
ganz dafür die ganzen corona kosten zu
organisieren und zu schultern
dort in den staatshaushalt zu greifen
und sich an den entscheidenden stellen
vom steuergeld zu bedienen um diese
schwere krise zu finanzieren
sie haben gesagt auch immer dass es sich
bei bestimmten bevölkerungsschichten
höhere steuern vorstellen könnten ganz
konkret wer muss künftig mit
steuererhöhungen rechnen und wer nicht
eins ist ganz klar wir werden in diesem
und dem nächsten jahr noch erhebliche
mittel brauchen
durch die wirtschaftliche krise und die
gesundheitliche krise zu kommen
danach können wir hoffen dass wir wieder
halbwegs normale haushalte aufstellen
können aber wir werden nicht in der
situation vor der krise seien und
deshalb glaube ich ist es ein gebot der
vernunft und der ehrlichkeit zu sagen
dass zunächst einmal steuersenkungen für
diejenigen die sehr viel geld verdienen
ein paar hunderttausend euro im jahr
nicht drin die steuersenkung ist wird ja
mehr geld gebrauchen sie halt einmal
damit anfangen es gibt ja schon welche
die diese forderung jetzt erheben das
wird auch glaube ich wenn wir uns im
nächsten jahr über die weitere zukunft
deutschlands an lässt sich der
bundestagswahl unterhalten parteien
geben die genau die forderung nach
steuersenkungen für spitzenverdiener
erheben weil sie sich davon irgendetwas
versprechen ich glaube das ist
unsolidarisch und ein falscher weg aber
darüber hinaus finde ich schon seit
langem dass wir nur als ein
leistungsfähiges gemeinwesen in der lage
sind unsere aufgaben zu bewältigen
und dazu gehört auch dass wir ein
gerechtes steuersystem haben und ja ich
bin seit langem der überzeugung dass die
sehr viel verdienen einen höheren
beitrag zur finanzierung des
gemeinwesens leisten müssen und zwar als
die heißeste band sie da eine ungefähre
höhe nennen verdienstgrenze wir haben
also für mich ist das das gleiche wie
für die meisten bürger wäre mehrere
hunderttausend euro im jahr verdient ist
bestimmt ein sehr gut aufgestellter
bürger
das ist toll dass man hier begonnen da
gibt es überhaupt nichts gegen zusagen
oder die werden eben ja die abonnenten
sodass er glaube ich ohnehin ein etwas
gerechteres steuersystem brauchen das
dann auch die kraft hat kleine und
mittlere einkommen zu entlasten was wir
ja auch erreichen müssen sie wollen
hören wir jetzt das kurzarbeitergeld
verlängern auf möglicherweise 24 monate
also zwei jahre heißt das ganz ganz
viele arbeitnehmer in deutschland sollen
wirklich erst nach der wahl merken dass
ihr job gar nicht mehr da ist
das ist unfug und im übrigen habe ich
die kurzarbeit als großes thema zur
krisenbekämpfung in der letzten
wirtschaftskrise 28 29
ja als arbeitsminister für deutschland
umgesetzt und populär gemacht und auch
damals habe ich stück für stück die
bezugsdauer auf 24 monate ausgeweitet
und es geschafft alle möglichen zu
überzeugen die anfangs sehr skeptisch
waren es geht bei der kurzarbeit um eine
ganz klare rechnung
viele unternehmen wollen an ihren
beschäftigten festhalten
viele unternehmen wissen die brauchen
wir wenn die krise vorbei ist wieder
und deshalb müssen sie von uns wissen ob
wir den ganzen weg mit dem unternehmen
und den arbeitnehmern aber nehmen zu
ende gehen darum ist die aussage wird
die 24 monate jetzt zeitnah wichtig weil
sonst trifft jemand in diesem jahr die
entscheidung mitarbeiter zu entlassen
der mit dieser information dass
vielleicht versucht hätte und vielleicht
ab nächstes jahr schon gar keine
kurzarbeit mehr braucht aber durch das
wissen dass wir die ganze strecke mit
gehen seine arbeitsplätze erhält und das
hat schon mal geklappt es ist in der
ganzen welt als das besondere deutsche
modell gelobt worden und es wird auch
diesmal klappen aber sind 24 monate noch
kurz sie sind nicht kurz das
kurzarbeitergeld hat der rat nicht die
bezug auf die dauer des bezugs sondern
auf die höhe der leistung die er nicht
so hoch ist wie der normale lohn und
deshalb finde ich sollte man das jetzt
auch nicht verballhornen das ist die
größte wirtschaftspolitische und
sozialpolitische tat aus deutschland ist
eine meisterleistung dass ich glaube da
gibt es auch völlige einigkeit die frage
ist ob die jobs danach noch da sind oder
ob man nicht was am leben hält was
möglicherweise leben war auch letztes
mal etwas das viel diskutiert worden ist
und es ist nicht so gekommen sondern
deutschland ist dadurch viel schneller
aus der krise gekommen war alle noch da
waren
während andere ihre entlassenen
arbeitnehmer erst mal wieder suchen
mussten die sich aber vielleicht was
anderes gesucht da sie garantieren dass
da keine strategischen gründen jetzt
dahinter stehen zu sagen okay bis zur
wahl lassen wir die alle noch in arbeit
finanzieren das schön mit den mitteln
der arbeitslosenversicherung
beziehungsweise dann vermutlich
irgendwann mit steuermitteln weil die
töpfe ja auch leer laufen und nach der
wahl sind denn die jobs leider weg das
garantiere ich ihnen nicht nur dass ich
sage das ist das ganze konzept ist und
dauerhaft die arbeitsplätze erhalten und
das will ich auch noch dazu sagen
für die unternehmen die nicht daran
glauben dass sie am ende ihre
beschäftigten brauchen wieder ist auch
die kurzarbeit zu teuer
irgendwelche kosten sind damit immer
verbunden und die entlassung kosten
werden nicht geringer wenn sie später
anfallen
deshalb sage ich es gibt eine innere
logik die dafür sorgt dass das nicht
missbraucht wahl wird und so war es beim
letzten großen test nun allerdings auch
um millionen arbeitsplätze schon mal und
es wird bei diesem noch größeren test
auch so sagt das sieht ja gigantische
kosten wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen
24 monate zu finanzieren möglicherweise
millionen arbeitnehmer die betroffen
sein werden haben sie schon mal nur
ungefähr es schwer das vielleicht zu
prognostizieren aber eine ungefähre
zielmarke was das kosten wird
wir beschäftigen uns gerade mit den
kosten einer verlängerung da könnte ich
ihn sogar genaue zahlen sagen weil
diskutiert haben aber ich möchte das als
gemeinschaftsleistung miteinander doch
gab es noch geheim größenordnung die
größenordnung wird aber sicherlich
zusätzliche milliarden umfassen so wie
bisher auch schon und das ist auch
richtig und zwar auch wovon wir ausgehen
können dass immer zusätzlich milliarden
sind 100 milliarden oder 18 milliarden
er in der größenordnung die sie jetzt
genannt haben vielleicht auch ein
bisschen darunter dass jetzt die
zusätzlichen aufwand betrifft aber
insgesamt ist das mit teure
veranstaltung und die brauchen wir auch
ich will ihnen eine frau vorstellen die
auf kurzarbeit gehen musste das ist nina
böhm hd uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist sie
arbeitet in der pflege und das genauso
guten abend frau böhmer wie lange schon
ich arbeite schon nach eger seit dem 16
das heißt ein ganzes arbeitsleben lang
das aber noch nicht ganz so lang ist wie
wir sehen frau war sie haben außerdem
ein buch geschrieben das welchen titel
trägt
der titel ist euren applaus könnt ihr
euch sonst wohin stecken oder in applaus
damit meinen sie das was ganz viele in
deutschland gemacht haben nämlich zu
gruner krise ihnen und ganz vielen
anderen pflegekräften nämlich
applaudiert haben auf dem balkon und sie
sagen das könnt ihr euch wohin stecken
und damit meinen sie möglicherweise auch
den vizekanzler
na ja also ich glaube schon dass der
applaus war nett gemeint war aber er hat
uns hat nichts gebracht
das heißt es war unter anderem jahr eine
kur ohne prämie versprochen bzw
die arbeitgeber waren dazu aufgefordert
eine solche zu zahlen ist die bei ihnen
schon angekommen
nein bei mir nicht das heißt sie haben
mussten auf kurzarbeit gehen wie lange
ich war jetzt seit märz seit mai in
kurzarbeit genau
und ja es läuft halt immer noch so ein
bisschen also die aufträge kommen ein
geschäft ein
das heißt sie arbeiten in der pflege und
dieser beruf hat ja bei ganz vielen
zumindest in der korona krise viel mehr
aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen und
trotzdem sind sie im grunde jetzt im
moment ein corona krisenverlierern
kurzarbeit anmelden müssen und wie
gesagt der premiere schon gar nicht bei
ihnen rumgekommen was ist jetzt die
erwartung an die bundesregierung von
ihnen also ich hoffe natürlich dass die
dass die missstände auf jeden fall so
plate aber das irritiert nicht ein
bisschen als ich hoffe natürlich dass
ein bisschen mehr auf die missstände
geachtet wird die natürlich schon seit
jahren herrschen in der pflege ja und
dass endlich etwas getan wird auch gegen
den personalmangel ja und dass uns ein
bisschen mehr wertschätzung auch
gegenüber kommt mehr wertschätzung der
scholz das ist ihr stichwort ich habe es
in den letzten tagen verfolgt sie
sprechen jetzt immer von der respekt
gesellschaft die sie erreichen wollen
das wäre jetzt genau ein fall für sie
sie sagt ja klar respekt und
wertschätzung das hilft hier aber auch
nicht so ganz mein wort darf halt nicht
bleiben es muss irgendwo konkret werden
also wo können sie konkret frau böhmer
was anbieten aktuell möglichst noch also
wir haben mittel mobilisiert um die
arbeitgeber in die lage zu versetzen
dass sie zusätzliches geld zahlen wir
haben auch steuern die beträge er machen
ausgelobt das ist bisher passiert und
deshalb brauchen wir ein ganz klares
programm und da kann ich den ärger
vollständig verstehen das ist das thema
über das sich die ganze zeit rede
wer respekt sagt darf nicht nur
klatschen der muss auch dafür sorgen
dass es dauerhaft bessere gehälter gibt
und es hat was mit tarifverträgen zu tun
und dass wir diese tarifverträge auch
allgemein verbindlich machen so dass
jedes unternehmen sie beachten muss ob
sie wollen oder nicht
und wenn das die kosten für die pflege
im krankenhaus oder eine
altenpflegeeinrichtung oder die
individuelle pflege irgendwo die dann
mit von vielen vor ort verbracht
ausgeübt wird erhöht dann müssen wir ein
system etablieren wo das nicht dazu
führt dass die bürger die pflege nicht
mehr bezahlen können aber trotzdem diese
zusätzlichen aufwendungen für mehr gut
ausgebildete und besser bezahlte
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
zustande kommt mein gefühl ist dass die
gesellschaft in der wir leben auch davon
lebt dass sie ein bisschen weg guckt all
die leute die fleißig sind im
pflegebereich das was wir gerade
diskutieren im einzelhandel was auch
viele unglaubliche umgetrieben hat
diese und in der fleischindustrie wo wir
es gerade diskutiert haben all diese
bereiche haben teilweise wirklich
unakzeptable arbeitsbedingungen und wir
dürfen nicht mehr weggucken es muss ein
großes gesellschaftliches programm geben
das zu ändern und das haben sie selber
weggeguckt die haben ganz lange regiert
haben sie wenn sie sagen wir dürfen
nicht länger wegducken haben sie vorher
weggeguckt nein ich habe nicht
weggeguckt das thema ist für mich kein
neues deshalb zum beispiel zählt zu den
vereinbarungen die die spd in der
jetzigen koalitionsvertrag durchgesetzt
hat dass wir ein gesetz machen wollen
für allgemeinverbindliche tarifverträge
im pflegebereich was ich eben gesagt
hatten dass wir jetzt voranbringen wir
müssen deshalb auch den mindestlohn
erhöhen
sie wissen dass sich die forderung nach
zwölf euro schon lange erhoben habe aber
das brauchen sie ja genauso auto in der
fleischindustrie in der pflege es muss
aufgeräumt werden in unserem ganzen land
das arbeitsverhältnisse betrifft ich
glaube wir dürfen diese etwas
eigenwillige art und weise uns damit
abzufinden dass ein teil der bürgerinnen
und bürger einfach schlecht bezahlt wird
und schwierige unsichere
arbeitsverhältnisse haben nicht mehr
akzeptieren und für mich geht es deshalb
immer um beides einmal um das geld und
die sicheren arbeitsplätze und die
tarifverträge aber zum zweiten auch das
will ich ausdrücklich sagen um den
respekt der damit verbunden ist dass man
diese leistung auch als gleichwertig
betrachtet
ich finde wer sehr viel geld verdient
meinetwegen auch zwei studiengänge
gemacht hat und fünf fremdsprachen
spricht soll sein geld haben aber er
soll nicht schlecht über die denken die
sich entschieden haben so eine wertvolle
leistung zu verbringen wie sie zum
beispiel mit der pflege verbunden ist
und dieser respekt muss sich in
anerkennung im gleichwertigkeit und in
richtigem geld und sicheren
arbeitsverhältnissen die da schlagen und
darum geht es macht ihnen das etwas
hoffnung frau böhmer
allgemeinverbindliche tarifverträge
unter anderem und bei ihnen ihnen wäre
ja erst mal geholfen überhaupt erst der
kurzarbeit wieder rauszukommen
ja also das war natürlich schön wenn
wenn es sowas wie richtige termin
verträge geben würde also es gibt es ja
schon tatsächlich in öffentlichen
krankenhaus
sagen aber es gibt natürlich auch viele
altenheime da kenne ich leute also das
sind gerade auch pflegehelfer die
verdienen irgendwie weniger als leute
die an der kasse arbeiten oder so und
das finde ich natürlich nicht schön weil
wir leisten natürlich sehr sehr viel
arbeit und die arbeiten halt auch
tagtäglich mit menschen und es geht um
leben und tod ja und da wäre natürlich
ein bisschen ja gehalt auch schon ein
bisschen mehr anerkennung ja ich glaube
das wissen wir irgendwie alle und
diskutieren darüber seit vielen vielen
jahren dass andere kinder und geben
natürlich gerade für sie in der pflege
auch einfach mehr gehalt bedeutet der
vizekanzler hat sich aber dazu bekannt
heute abend vielleicht nehmen wir das
als klares kleines bekenntnis für sie
frau böhmer mit herzlichen dank dass sie
mitgemacht haben uns heute zugeschaltet
waren
aus berlin danke herzlich
wir wollen einmal sprechen über weitere
maßnahmen in der korona krise es wird
jetzt auch diskutiert nicht nur das
kurzarbeitergeld wie sie es gerade auch
nochmal bestätigt haben zu verlängern
sondern auch eine vier tage woche
möglicherweise einzuführen wie stehen
sie dazu
bei voller bezahlung über arbeitszeit
wird ja abgesehen von den gesetzlichen
rahmenbedingungen durch tarifverträge
entschieden
und ganz klar die ig metall hat jetzt
für die automobilindustrie die sich ja
in vielen umbrüchen befindet gesagt das
ist jetzt vielleicht der richtige
zeitpunkt eine solche große umbruch
situation dadurch zu begleiten dass man
die arbeitszeit in der branche
auf diese weise reduziert und dadurch
dafür sorgt dass die unternehmen und die
beschäftigten die anpassungs situation
hin zu anderen produktionsweisen zu
elektrifizierter mobilität hinbekommen
können ohne dass das arbeitsplätze
kostet ich finde das ist eine sehr
vertretbare und gut überlegte idee der
gewerkschaft stehen sie an der seite der
gewerkschaften unterstützen als sie
sagen die sind zuständig das
auszuhandeln aber da japan so dann
schalte sich für eine völlig
nachvollziehbare idee die für mich auch
nicht überraschend ist weil sie mir auch
schon verschiedentlich dargestellt
worden ist ein sehr intensiv in kontakt
mit den gewerkschaften
und ich glaube da wird sehr sorgfältig
darüber nachgedacht wie kriegen wir das
hin dass wir das schaffen worum es für
unsere land in den nächsten zehn jahren
ohnehin geht nämlich erstklassige
moderne arbeitsplätze mit neuen
technologien die trotzdem gutes
einkommen schaffen und in so einer
umbruchsituation muss man sich natürlich
genau überlegen wie kommen wir da hin
wir bleiben noch mal im moment beim
thema corona es gab eine gewaltige
corona pangl gerade in bayern
dort sind ganz ganz viele
urlaubsrückkehrer auf der autobahn an
einer massen an drei verschiedenen
massentests anlagen getestet worden und
dann hat man eben die dokumente dort mit
bleistift ausgefüllt und nachher konnte
man nicht mehr richtig nachvollziehen wo
ganz ganz viele auch positiv getestete
denn geblieben sind immer noch fehlen 45
positiv getestete die man nicht mehr
auftreiben kann
würden sie da sagen da in so einer krise
kann schon mal passieren oder
schwerwiegende panne darf nicht
passieren das ist eine schwerwiegende
panne trotzdem werde ich mich jetzt
nicht hinstellen und erst mal auf andere
zeigen
es muss jetzt alles dafür gesorgt werden
dass erstmal die fehlenden auch noch
informiert werden können was wird nichts
werden und das wird nichts werden
die finden also es deutet zumindest
einiges darauf den die welt dazu sagen
es ist auch ganz wichtig dass das für
alle noch mal als aufbruch genutzt wird
sehr sorgfältig zu sein denn wenn sich
40.000 menschen testen lassen
dann tun sie das ja weil sie auf einen
guten start vertrauen der die sache im
griff hat und im internationalen
vergleich haben wir sie ja auch ganz gut
im griff
und dieses vertrauen dass die bürger und
bürger in die regierung der bundesländer
und die bundesregierung setzen
das dürfen wir nicht aufs spiel setzen
dann müssen wir hart dran arbeiten aber
ist der shooter doch genau das vertrauen
dort vor ort auskennen hier in dem
bundesland wo viele in deutschland
bisher gesagt mensch also die haben es
im griff guckt euch mal den söder an der
macht es richtig gut jetzt sagt bei ihm
vor der haustür und in seinem bundesland
ausgerechnet dort vertrauen erschüttert
grosse panne hat es nicht funktioniert
also haben die das nicht so gut im griff
wie erwartet ich hoffe dass jetzt alle
sich alle mühe geben die sache in
ordnung zu kriegen wir das noch mal
sagen das ist eine schwere panne das
darf man auch nicht schönreden und vor
allem darf man nicht das sagen was sie
da eingangs als variante geschildert
haben
passt schon aber das ist jetzt die
hauptaufgabe wir können ja die zeit
nicht zurückdrehen
also nochmal maximale aufklärung nur
noch mal bei den 45 fällen ist mit
bleistift ausgefüllt worden
wahrscheinlich keine telefonnummer
hinterlegt oder ein falscher name
aufgepinselt relativ unwahrscheinlich
dass man diese fälle noch findet
möglicherweise auch in nordrhein
westfalen dann verschwunden oder in
hamburg verschwunden bei ihnen vor der
haustür verschwunden
in potsdam zum beispiel muss man leben
kann man nichts anderes mache ich glaube
dass wir einfach sehen müssen
das darf nicht wieder passieren und
vielleicht ist es denn für den einen
oder anderen hinweis wie sorgfältig man
jede entscheidung vorbereiten aber sie
reden immer wieder über sorgfalt hat der
ministerpräsident hat markus söder dort
einen fehler begangen bei fragen sie
ihnen dass ich finde er hat er hat sich
geäußert ist die frage wie sie es
beurteilen
na ja aber ich finde wenn jetzt in so an
der schweren zeit politiker
unterschiedlicher parteien sich vor
allem damit beschäftigen andere
politiker zu beschimpfen dann kommen wir
auch nicht weiter
also mache ich das nicht können sie auch
zimmer nachfragen dass das leute fragen
wir sie mal nach ja das war die frage
weil weil viele ja gesagt haben bayern
ist ein vorbild und herr söder der
sinngemäß selbst gesagt mensch an
bayerns grenzen wird die korona grenze
deutschlands verteidigt sozusagen wir
schützen euch alle vor kroner genau das
ist nicht was vielleicht sollten wir
wissen es bleibt immer eine
gemeinschaftsleistung
und ich finde es sehr gut dass in
deutschland nicht irgendwo einer
entscheidet wie es geht sondern wir das
immer sorgfältig miteinander diskutieren
da kommen bessere entscheidung aus dann
fragen wir nicht ganz zehn mal nach
sondern machen hier ein haken dran was
ist das wichtigste ihrer auffassung nach
nachdem die spd nun gesagt hat sie
sollen es sein im nächsten jahr sollen
spd kanzlerkandidat sein was das
wichtigste was ein kanzler ihrer
auffassung nach können muss eine
eigenschaft die ja auf jeden fall haben
muss er muss in der lage sein
entscheidungen zu treffen wer muss sehr
viel erfahrung haben und dann musste der
lage sein mit krisen umzugehen wenn sie
sich die letzten 20 jahre aber
wahrscheinlich noch viel länger
rückwärts anschauen dann werden sie
sehen viele der dinge
die große veränderung mit sich gebracht
hatten standen in keinem wahlprogramm
waren in keiner bundestagswahl
diskutiert und waren trotzdem
herausforderung die man so
auflösen musste und das kann man
überhaupt noch hinkriegen wenn man mit
erfahrung und mit einer gewissen
klarheit und mit der bereitschaft
entscheidung zu treffen und dann in
einer solchen situation reagieren kann
das ist das erste und das zweite ich
sage das ausdrücklich weil das ja keine
abstrakte sache ist ohne ein gutes herz
wird es nicht gehen
das ist ein gutes herz das man schon das
gefühl hat dass unser land nur dann
funktioniert wenn alle dabei gut
zurechtkommen und jeder das gefühl es
geht in der politik auch um licht und
dass wir ein besseres miteinander als
zielstellung auch von politik haben es
muss zuversicht geben und solidarität
unterschiede entscheidet sieht es von
anderen ein gutes herz also würde ihnen
in der reihe
habeck söder sparen würde ihn da jemand
einfallen der kein gutes herz so etwas
werde ich nie machen und habe ich noch
nicht gemacht dass ich über andere rede
und ich glaube auch dass das ein ganz
schlechter stil ist jetzt mal ein
bisschen verbreitet ist aber an dem ich
mich nicht beteiligen
das unterscheidet mich vielleicht von
anderen aber an dieser haltung dass ich
für die spd wäre für mich als künftigen
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
in dem ich erzähle was wir können und
was wir vorhaben und was ich will und
was ich kann glaube dass du richtig
haben einmal auf der straße gefragt wie
die deutschen oder zumindest einige
deutsche eigentlich sie sehen was sie
mit ihrem namen und dem gesicht
verbinden eine kurze frage was fällt
ihnen zu diesem mann hätte er soll nicht
kanzler werden empfiehlt dass das
charisma
was für den namen nicht alle noch
kornfeld mitterfels so können sie sich
vorstellen dass er der nächste kanzler
werden könnte kommen wir uns und sie
auch nicht sterben schloss erster
bürgermeister hamburgs jetzt
finanzminister kanzlerkandidaten
genannten spd schon zum markt hat
kriegsminister genau gut 100 typische
hamburger aber aus meiner sicht leider
in der falschen partei
das waren die streber am ende aber eines
bleibt hängen dann am ende in der
falschen partei das hat die spd
möglicherweise oder mal einige in der
spd auch lange gedacht und dann zeigt
haben sogar walter borjans und ersten am
ende gesagt jetzt nachdem sie es bei der
kürzung vorsitzende noch unbedingt
verhindern wollten dass sie es werden
jetzt bei der kanzlerkandidatur
doch eingeschränkt und plötzlich wollen
sie das dach nehmen sie unsere zuschauer
ein bisschen mit wie kann es da hinter
den kulissen dazu als wie kam es dabei
den beiden zum stimmungswechsel wie sehr
mussten sie da wären wir für gespräche
mussten für die wii kommt zu was die spd
war vor einem jahr in einer wirklich
dramatischen situation
wir haben uns das stück für stück
herausgearbeitet und in der zeit in der
wir jetzt eng zusammengearbeitet haben
die parteivorsitzenden der
fraktionsvorsitzende und ich haben alle
gemerkt dass wir uns aufeinander
verlassen können dass wir ein
gemeinsames ziel verfolgen und daraus
machen wir jetzt was wir wollen die
bürgerinnen bürger mit einer
geschlossenen spd überraschen das soll
die ganze zeit bis zur bundestagswahl
und weit darüber hinaus funktionieren
und ich glaube das kann auch gelingen
und unser ziel ist unbedingt auch dafür
zu sorgen dass wir all das mobilisieren
dass die spd an bandbreite hat und
gleichzeitig die tatsache dass viele
bürgerinnen und bürger sogar solche die
eigentlich andere parteien besser finden
mit mir was anfangen können dafür nutzen
dass das ergebnis der spd noch besser
wird wenn wir schreiben ja ergebnisse
weit über 20 prozent
weit über 20 verhindert weiter bei uns
gesagt in einem anderen interview auf
jeden fall 30 zitieren ehrgeiz ist es
immer gut wir arbeiten uns jetzt vor von
ergebnissen die nicht befriedigen waren
ein bisschen darf man aus
erste rückmeldungen hoffen dass das
große projekt klappen wird
ob hinter gerne so nelly bologna die
latte so hoch monat für monat er sagt ja
unsere ergebnisse verbessern
ich will kanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland werden als sozialdemokrat
und ich glaube wir können das bekommt
noch einmal ganz kurz beide zielen beim
gut walter bau jetzt sagt 30 da wollen
sie jetzt nicht so ganz genau darauf
eingehen aber sagen so ernähren wir uns
langsam an
der weg ist noch selbstbewusster und er
sagt er will auf jeden fall mit den
grünen stärkste kraft werden sagen sie
dass auch sie wollen auf jeden fall die
cdu/csu schlagen
wir wollen dass die cdu/csu sich in der
opposition wieder findet und dass die
sozialdemokratische partei so stark ist
dass sie den kanzler stellt klappt das
aber was anderes stärkste partei zu
werden stärkste kraft zu bleiben also
der der welt war heute so selbstbewusste
hat er gesagt das erledigen wir auch
cdu/csu wurden auch mal andere gesetz
der 30 nicht zu der zweite muss um die
führung kämpfen
wir kämpfen dafür dass wir erst mal in
die rolle des zweiten kommen das kann
klappen und sieht ja ein bisschen danach
aus und natürlich kämpfen wir um die
führung und trauen uns ganz schön was zu
aber ich glaube dass wir jetzt keinen
wettbewerb der gross sprecher machen
sollten sondern ein bisschen mal davon
ausgehen sind die bürgerinnen und bürger
die entscheiden wer der nächste kanzler
wird ja das ist ja klar
und da bin ich ziemlich zuversichtlich
geht ja nur um die ziele aber sie sagen
erst mal zweiter ist auch schon in
ordnung als nein das ist nicht meine
aussage ich finde nur dass wir den
ehrgeiz den wir haben jetzt nicht
dadurch hier machen das jetzt irgendwie
die nächste woche jemand kommt und sagt
unter 40 prozent ist ganz schlecht also
wir kommen von schlechten ausgangswerten
wir werden bei sehr guten ergebnissen
enden und dieses ergebnis die grundlage
dafür bilden dass die spd in der
nächsten regierung den kanzler stellt
ich will doch auf ein zitat hinaus das
von herrn söder auf kommt der hatte
gesagt kanzler kann wer krise kann und
so klang das eben auch ein bisschen bei
ihnen durch die haben gesagt der nächste
kanzler muss auf jeden fall eine
erfahrung mitbringen der muss zeigen
dass er eben in krisen steht diese
bewältigen kann
noch toller wäre doch wenn man mit dem
kanzler gar nicht erst in die krise käme
dass wir noch toller toller aber klar
muss auch ein kanzler krise können dem
stimme ich ausdrücklich zu
und das ist
etwas womit die spd und auch ich färbe
werde in der nächsten zeit natürlich ist
unter denen die sich absehbar und das
amt des bundeskanzlers der
bundesrepublik deutschland bewerben
werden vermutlich nur eine der die
erfahrung hat die man im internationalen
nationalen geschäft der regierung dieses
landes braucht und das sind ich glaube
ich wir wollen einmal hören was unsere
zuschauer unter einer von ihnen wissen
wollen louis bormann hat uns diese frage
per video geschickt
herr scholz wenn sie bereit sind mit den
linken zusammenzugehen
dann werden sie für mich absolut
unwählbar sind sie weiterhin bereit für
eine koalition mit den linken haben eine
klare haltung übrigens seit sieben
jahren das hat sigmar gabriel schon
durchgesetzt und die lautet wer regieren
will muss regierungsfähig sein
ich glaube da haben einige noch was
vorsicht ja der herr bormann sagte er
würde sie möglicherweise wählen wenn er
vor der wahl von ihnen eine klare
antwort bekommt ob es ist mit denen
machen oder nicht und wenn sie es mit
denen machen sagt der mann wählte sie
nicht ja aber ich glaube wir sind jetzt
in einer situation in der wir ein
bisschen auf die inhalte gucken müssen
was passiert und ich habe ganz klare
haltung
erstens deutschland muss eine starke
wirtschaftsnationen sein mit vielen
zukunftsfähigen arbeitsplätzen zweitens
man muss mit dem geld vernünftig umgehen
drittens wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
unsere sicherheit gewährleistet bleibt
auch in der nato
und viertens müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass europa vorankommt und daran werde
ich alle messen und das glaube ich weiß
jeder da sind noch nicht alle in einer
situation wo man sagen kann daher sind
alle fragen beantwortet sie haben große
zweifel ihre vorsitzenden ja nicht die
sagen ganz klar während links bündnis
völlig andere haltung erzählen ich sehe
keine andere haltung denn die
beschlusslage ist seit vielen jahren
gemeinsam
es hängt von den anderen ab und die
müssen sich jetzt alle bahnstrecke aber
von denen kriegt man ja heute eine ganz
klare antwort der wirst du herr baumann
heute wähle ich nicht bei ihnen muss das
noch nicht lieben sie die demokratie und
die demokratie besteht darin dass wir
jetzt in einer situation sind in der
alle die große herausforderung
bewältigen müssen sich am ernst
mit dem fragen die für die zukunft
unseres landes wichtig sind zu
beschäftigen
und da werde ich niemanden aus der sache
raus lassen die punkte die ich eben
genannt hat und ich hätte noch eine
längere liste muss jeder beantworten der
in diesem land regieren aber eine
antwort auf die frage werden sie vor der
wahl nicht anders geben als jetzt also
es gibt für ein bormann gibt es keine
klare antwort er möchte von ihnen wissen
mit links ja oder nein die gibt es
vorher war ich glaube die wollen eine
antwort wissen ob sie einen
sozialdemokratischen kanzler bekommen
und was das für eine politik ist so wie
wenn der markt die linkspartei nicht
deswegen will er auf keinen fall
riskieren dass die anderen auch nicht
ich bin nämlich in der spd was ist heute
noch ich will noch mal dazu sagen lassen
sie uns mal über die politik für
deutschland gut die haben wir ganz viel
gemacht anfangs schon und kommen wir
gleich wieder zurück und trotzdem gehört
auch das als zentralen punkt für viele
viele zuschauer und leser dazu was es
heute noch links an ihnen ich bin
sozialdemokrat seit meinem 17 lebensjahr
und was ist links anni dass das das ist
links vielen in der partei nicht mehr so
war sie haben gewaltigen weg auch
gemacht sie sind nicht nur optisch haben
sich gewaltig verändert sondern auch vom
weg von ganz ganz weit links außen und
sozialistischen zielen
doch sehr weit in die mitte und eben als
vizekanzler in der großen koalition
deswegen frage völlig berechtigt was ist
noch so richtig links inhaltlich ich bin
für soziale gerechtigkeit in diesem land
dass der sozialstaat stabil wird und das
wird die große frage des nächsten jahres
sein denn ein teil unserer politischen
wettbewerber wird an dem herumbasteln
wollenden zusammenstreichen wollen als
konsequenz aus der rückrunde krise ich
bin für ein gerechtes steuersystem bin
dafür dass wir die europäische union
voranbringen dass wir jetzt dafür sorgen
dass es ein souveränes europa in der
lage ist so stark zu sein dass wir nicht
von all diesen leuten bestimmt werden
die jeweils irland first sehen davon
gibt es ein paar zu viele wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die welt sicherer wird
in dem wir miteinander kooperieren warum
durften die mitglieder alle noch ganz
ganz vielen regionalkonferenzen ihre
vorsitzenden wählen aber der
kanzlerkandidat wurde nun bestimmt
irgendwie im hinterzimmer in der
diskussion über die frage der wahl eines
und einer vorsitzenden in der spd nach
für alle klar dass sie sich zu dieser
frage auch äußern wie wir das machen
wollen
die jetzigen parteivorsitzenden haben
wie fast alle anderen auch gesagt dass
es dem mitgliederentscheid gibt über die
vorsitzenden frage aber dass das andere
auf vorschlag der vorsitzenden von
partei verstanden unter dem parteitag
entschieden wir sonst werden sie es
nicht geworden
doch bin ich ziemlich sicher aber es ist
trotzdem so dass wir uns gesagt haben
einmal machen wir das und jetzt wollen
die bürgern und bürger klarheit haben
woran sie mit uns sind und werden sie es
ohne corona gewesen ist es spekulativ
zugegeben aber ohne corona krise stünden
sie dann jetzt hier als kanzlerkandidat
ich glaube schon denn die gute
zusammenarbeit des fraktionsvorsitzenden
der parteivorsitzenden mit mir hat ja
schon lange vorher eingesetzt und wir
haben ganz schön was erreicht ich will
ihn noch jemand vorstellen der aus essen
kommt aus nordrhein-westfalen vielleicht
so aus dem herzen der sozialdemokratie
und das ist hier der chef der ersten
tafel der uns von dort nämlich aus
seinem kleinen büro und der essener
tafel zugeschaltet ist schön gut
nachahmen tester beschreiben sie mal wie
tief sie mit der sozialdemokratie
verwurzelt sind ja wie soll ich sagen
von geburt ein sozialdemokrat mein vater
war jahrelang gesetzt sozialdemokrat und
ich war selber habe selber 44 jahre lang
diese partei gewählt
erstmalig bei der letzten europawahl
habe ich eine andere partei wählen
müssen weil die spd wir nicht mehr
glaubwürdig war durch ihre sie ganzes
führungsgerangel führungs gehetze und
führungsspieler ist da keine
glaubwürdigkeit mehr für den wähler da
in meinen augen
scholz war lange dabei ist jetzt ganz an
der spitze wenn sie sagen
führungsgerangel usw
ja also ich will olaf scholz wenig
rausnehmen oder stolz ist für mich
sicherlich einer der der kandidaten die
ihrigen frage geben aber die art und
weise wie er jetzt auf den thron gehoben
worden ist ist sowas von unglaubwürdig
und lächerlich
von seiner parteispitze von fresken die
zwei tage vorher noch gesagt hat sie
will mit den linken koalieren sie will
sie kann sich eine kleine partei führung
unter dem vorsitz einer grünen
parteivorsitzenden vorstellen und die
sich wochen und monate lang mit dem
herrn scholz fürchterlich gerieben hat
ich will sich schon bald sagen bisschen
unter die gürtellinie und ihn jetzt auf
einmal ins auf den thron hebt ist für
mich unglaubwürdig
und wenn dann noch ein camping gunners
haben einmal aus dem gebüsch kommt der
auch bis vor wenigen tagen noch
absoluter gegner von der scholz war und
jetzt auf einmal sagt er trägt das mit
kann ich das als wähler nicht mehr
nachvollziehen das ist für mich alles
nicht glaubwürdig können sie ist dem
sozialdemokraten sator herr scholz
erklären weil natürlich mutet das ein
bisschen seltsam an ersten und walter
borjans team massiv wahlkampf wirklich
gegen sie gemacht haben die wirklich
wollten dass sie es auf keinen fall
werden spd-vorsitzender und sie hat eben
dann den eintracht in dieser woche
stehen sie alle nebeneinander und dann
wird verkündet er stolz ist der richtige
kandidat erklären sie seien sator
erstmal möchte ich unbedingt dass er bei
der nächsten bundestagswahl die spd
wählt und auch mich und ich habe auch
die hoffnung dass das irgendwie gelingen
wird so was geht ja nicht von einem tag
auf den anderen
denn die entscheidung die er uns eben
geschildert hat ist ja auch in ihm
gereift aus vielen vielen ereignissen
die da zusammengekommen sind sie kennen
sich vermutlich oder kennen zumindest
die geschichte von herrn sator dort aus
essen
die kenne ich und ich finde er macht
eine ziemlich gute arbeit das will ich
ausdrücklich dazu sagen
insofern ist mir ganz wichtig zu sagen
mit meiner kandidatur verbinde ich das
ziel das nicht von einem tag auf den
anderen aber über die zeit hinweg
ja und viele die so sind wie er sich für
die spd und auch für mich als kanzler
der republik entscheiden und dass wir
all diejenigen die mal ihr vertrauen in
die spd investiert haben wieder zusammen
gewinnen und dazu gibt es eine
voraussetzung auf dich unbedingt
bestanden habe sonst wäre ich auch nicht
angetreten als
kanzlerkandidat der spd nämlich dass das
aus einer geschlossenheit in der spd
heraus kommt und dass wir jetzt nicht so
tun als ob wir jetzt über alle fragen
immer einer meinung während das ist
nirgendwo so das ist auch unglaubwürdig
war dass man nicht regieren da sind der
größten und versucht den handel
vorschießen
und das glaube ich ist passiert die spd
muss das jetzt auch jeden tag beweisen
ist das schon mal eine woche gut
gegangen
das spricht dafür dass es jetzt auch
weit über ein jahr gut eine woche vor
einer woche hat schon geklappt da sagt
der scholz mensch das muss doch nein
sagt er so nah dass das nicht erreicht
nein das habe ich nicht gesagt
ausdrücken ich habe gesagt das muss die
ganze zeit zu bleiben denn ich will
ihnen unbedingt überzeugen und ich
möchte sogar dass er wieder bei uns
alles mitmacht solange die spd den weg
nach links ein schlecht mit dieser
sed-nachfolgepartei ich sag mal kugelt
gibt es da für die meisten der spd
derart spd wähler keinen weg zurück
als wichtiger vor neun monaten
angetreten mit dieser aussage von 30
prozent die er erreichen will und moment
hängen die immer noch bei 15 prozent
und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
dass sich das ändert in der nächsten
zeit
wenn da keine klare aussage zu
zusammenarbeit mit der linken kommt weil
die linke ist nicht unbedingt für die
meisten menschen dieser republik eine
demokratische vereinigung
das ist das eine was der sator von ihnen
fordert um ebene sein kreuz sind dann
doch wieder bei der spd zu machen gibt
es noch weitere forderungen ganz klar
von ihnen und in aller kürze seite was
sie dazu bewegen würde eben dann das
kreuz den ball scholz beziehungsweise
bei spd zu machen also die spd hat ja in
der regierungspolitik in der
regierungsarbeit einige gute mitarbeiter
eingesetzt und leider hat die spd ist
versäumt diese guten dinge die sie
erreicht hat ich denn da machen mit
hubertus heil hat sich hier einiges
bewegt haben
sachen auch in die bevölkerung zu
bringen immer wieder kam diese
grabenkämpfe dazwischen diese
grabenkämpfe innerhalb der parteiführung
die die wähler vergrault haben
ich denke das hat angefangen mit dem
miura prozent und danach die frau nahles
die ja sicherlich nicht dazu geführt
dass die spd ihren umfragewerten
gestiegen ist und diese geschichte mit
dem hat mit der wahl zum
parteivorsitzenden noch
parteivorsitzender hat sicherlich auch
nicht dazu geführt dass ich alt spd
wähler wieder dazu bewegen können diese
partei zu wählen waren sie da eigentlich
das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt für
einen sator dass diese grabenkämpfe
aufhören dass diese hinter dem rücken
gerede und den anderen stürzen und so
weiter in der spd endlich auch etwa sie
da eigentlich nie beteiligt in den
letzten jahren nein kein schlechtes
gewissen und nichts was sie gegenüber
herrn sator jetzt aufbauen müssen nein
und sie können für das wahljahr
versprechen das auch nichts zu tun sie
stehen jetzt an der spitze und bildet
sich ein team vermutlich in den nächsten
monaten bin ich auch sehr froh darüber
dass wir die entscheidung so früh
getroffen haben
jetzt wissen die bürger nun bürger woran
sie mit der spd sind und dass sie mich
als kanzlerkandidaten der spd bekommen
und die lange zeit ist ja auch ein
großer glaubwürdigkeitstest und ich will
dass wir den bestehen und ich bin auch
sicher dass wir das tun und dass wir
darüber viele wieder zurückgewinnen
können und noch viele zusätzlich
überzeugen also der kanzlerkandidat der
spd stellt sich diesem
glaubwürdigkeitstest der sator nach
essen wir bleiben bei ihnen auf jeden
fall dran an der geschichte und
verfolgen dann bist du var lassen sie
uns den kontakt bleiben ob sie am ende
überzeugt sind von dem spd
kanzlerkandidaten oder eben nach so
vielen jahren sozialdemokratie noch
nicht gibt es irgendwas von
und martin schulz was sie gelernt haben
ein fehler den sie auf keinen fall
machen werden wir lernen aus allem dass
wir machen immer gemeinsam
ich habe mir fest vorgenommen mit einem
klaren politischen programm anzutreten
ich habe auch die drei hauptpunkte
genannt das eine ist respekt der respekt
gesellschaft darüber haben wir schon
gesprochen
das zweite ist wie kriegen wir das hin
dass die bürgerin und bürger wieder
zuversicht haben dass es besser wird in
diesem land und das hat auch etwas damit
zu tun dass wir uns real wird unsere
wirtschaftlichen leistungskraft mit
unserer technologischen kompetenz
zutrauen zum beispiel den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten
dafür zu sorgen dass es mehr erneuerbare
energien gibt dafür zu sorgen dass wir
die elektrifizierung der verkehre
hinkriegen die wasserstoffwirtschaft
umzusetzen dass wir das mit der
digitalisierung hinkriegen denn die
meisten wollen schon dass wir all die
neuen sachen machen
sie wollen nur sicher sein dass das auch
aus deutschland geht und das ist gute
arbeitsplätze geben das dritte thema
europa das war ein stück des
wahlprogramms des spd-kanzlerkandidaten
olaf scholz vielen dank dafür bis
hierhin vielen dank jörg sator nach
essen wir wollen einmal schnitt machen
strich unter die in politik und wollen
auf das schauen was im moment in
weißrussland passiert die bilder von
dort sind gewaltig die uns da seit gut
einer woche erreichen heute abend gab es
eine großdemonstration der auf der
straße das sind menschen mit sehr sehr
viel mut weil sie sehr sehr schlimmes
befürchten müssen als oppositionelle
oder als diejenigen die gegen den
diktator dort demonstrieren gehen gegen
lukaschenko das sind aktuelle bilder
dort aus wind aus der hauptstadt von
weißrussland und dort wollen wir jetzt
einmal schalten zu meinen kollegen paul
ronzheimer der diese proteste heute sehe
ich vor ort angeschaut hat und voller
eindrücke von diesem großdemonstration
zurückgekommen ist paul schilder uns ein
bisschen etwas über die stimmung dort
auf den straßen und vor allen dingen
auch auf die über die aussichten dieser
protest jetzt ja ich bin in der tat
gerade eben erst zurückgekommen von den
demonstrationen ist war auf den straßen
so viel los wie noch nie
muss man sagen es waren über
hunderttausend menschen in minsk
die menschen sind friedlich
demonstrieren gegangen die polizei ist
dort nicht eingeschritten bei dieser
großdemo die es in dieser form in dieser
größe noch nie gegeben hat aber
gleichzeitig darf es am morgen die erste
demonstration wo der diktator
lukaschenko aufgetaucht ist und er hat
eine rede gehalten muss man sagen hat
gesagt selbst wenn er stiert selbst wenn
er tot ist will er noch präsident
bleiben wer hat ganz klar gemacht dass
er nicht abtreten will und besonders
beunruhigend hierfür viele demonstranten
ist die tatsache dass sie befürchten
könnten dass putin der russische
präsident lukaschenko am ende helfen
wird und die große angst der
demonstranten hier mist ist dass es
wieder gewalt gibt und lieber kite neben
mir sitzt jemand er diese gewalt erlebt
hat es ist alexis 23 jahre alt
mechatroniker war bei einer
demonstration alles erklären was dir
passiert es zeigt uns was hier passiert
ist - und das hat ja man hat müssen die
kurve des balls kapelle bis heute nur
mit medizin studieren können das ist wie
beim schreiben dieses menschen zu
schneiden das interview ist
ja alex hat uns diese dramatischen
erlebnisse schildert er dort auf der
polizeiwache erlebt hat er wurde
festgenommen auf einer demonstration
wurde mit einem polizeitransporter in
eine dunkle kammer gebracht dort habe
auf ihn eingeschlagen mit einem
gummiknüppel man hat ihm eine 15 auf den
oberschenkeln wir mal und gleichzeitig
hier
man sieht es auch seinem pullover diese
15 hat man dort draußen mal bei mir
gesagt hat alex du hast jetzt keinen
namen mehr
du hast noch nur noch eine nummer und
man hat gesagt wird du musst jetzt
brüllen alexander lukaschenko als der
beste präsident der welt dass man sieht
die kräfte sind hier zu allem bereiten
und wenn ich mit einer extrem den ich
gestern das erste mal getroffen habe
spreche oder wenn ich mit den
demonstranten auf der straße spreche
dann fragen sie was tut deutschland
eigentlich was kann deutschland tun und
die frage gerichtet auch an den
vizekanzler wie cannes oder scholz
niemanden wie alex schützen und vor
allem wie kann er dafür sorgen dass
derjenige der die wahlbetrug begangen
hat alexander lukaschenko endlich
abtritt schon jetzt gibt mir direkt
weiter die frage von paulus minsk das
erste ist dass wir jetzt europäische
union gemeinsam handeln das ist es sehr
gut dass es erste beschlüsse zu
sanktionen gegeben hat die die
außenminister miteinander getroffen
haben weil es zeigt dass wir nicht
akzeptieren dass dort geschieht ich
finde man kann das schon sehr klar
beschreiben der lukaschenko hat keine
mehrheit mehr in seinem volk es durch
und wenn es nur nach demokratischen
regeln gibt geht dann wird er nicht mehr
lange im amt sein und wir müssen jetzt
gewissermaßen mit dem was wir machen
dafür sorge tragen dass die kraft und
der mut
dann ist es ja ein unglaublicher mut den
ganz viele der jeden tag gegenwärtig
zeigen dass dieser mut auch seine kraft
entfalten kann und dass es möglich ist
dadurch auch veränderungen zu sie haben
gesagt wenn es nach demokratischen
regeln geht ich glaube das können wir
nach den bildern endgültig sagen dass
das nicht der fall das ist nicht der
fall
das ist ein schlimmer diktator und
deshalb braucht er auch klar
klare sprache aber sind wir alle das war
ja die frage auch von paul und offenbar
auch von ganz ganz vielen die da so
mutig wie sie es beschrieben haben auf
die straße gehen sind wir selber oder es
unsere sind unsere regierung hier in
europa mutig genug wenn wir diese bilder
von den hunderttausenden dort auf der
straße sehen sind wir dann mutig genug
nach einer woche zu sagen wir warten
jetzt mal über sanktionen ist das alles
können sie sagen da haben wir alles
getan die zu unterstützen dort in minsk
wir müssen entschlossen und klar sein
die beschlüsse der außenminister werden
sicherlich nicht das letzte sein was wir
zu tun haben und die ganze zeit bei
dieser linie bleiben ich glaube das ist
die sprache die jetzt verstanden werden
muss und das ist unsere möglichkeit die
dort existiert das wir zeigen so geht
das nicht und man kann mit dieser
vorgehensweise nicht durchkommen also
ganz konkret sanktionen müssen erfolgen
in welcher härte welche sanktionen das
muss hier wird es ganz konkret abgewogen
werden
man muss ja auch noch immer noch was zu
tun haben wenn man gewissermaßen das
macht den ich stelle mir vor dass das
schon eine längere zeit sein wird und
das was wir tun können ist eben klar zu
sein entschieden zu sein und deshalb bin
ich froh das erste entscheidung
getroffen worden sind die die dort auf
die straße gehen paul die wollen
natürlich die werden jetzt nicht für
sanktionen sondern die werden dafür dass
lukaschenko weg ist ich wäre auch dafür
sie werden auch ja ich glaube dass wir
auf diese art und weise mit seinem volk
umgeht jede legitimation für die
regierung des landes verloren also
lukaschenko muss weg das nehmen wir auch
hier mit vom vizekanzler ist eine
entscheidung die weißrussland selber
treffen muss ich glaube dass mehr
weißrussland hat versucht die
entscheidung selber leider bis jetzt
ausdrücklich dazu sagen aber wir müssen
ja immer klar dass die das was unsere
möglichkeiten sind und unsere
möglichkeit besteht darin dass wir in
der sache entschieden sind
und ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass
dieser präsident keine legitimation mehr
hat sonst würde nicht mit so
unglaublicher so brutaler gewalt agieren
und die tatsache dass sich überhaupt
niemand gegenwärtig einschüchtern lässt
dass viele menschen sehr viel riskieren
ist ja auch eine große hoffnung der
demokratie
denn letztendlich ist die demokratie ja
etwas
das aus dem volk wächst und auf der
kraft des volkes beruht und das zeigt
sich hier paul noch einmal zu dir nach
minsk
darüber kann ich glaube alexej zum
beispiel der neben mir sitzt und viele
andere demonstranten haben eben auch die
große angst dass wladimir putin hier
eingreifen könnte und lukaschenko stützt
weil wladimir putin eben nicht will dass
in seinem nachbarstaat eine
demonstration dazu führt zu einer
demokratischen bewegung und sie haben
diese angst dass das passieren könnte
den nächsten tag wenn man das russische
staatsfernsehen zum beispiel sieht dann
werden da die üblichen
verschwörungstheorien gefahren das wird
mit der ukraine verglichen eine
angebliche attacke aus polen und die
frage die sich hier auch viele
demonstranten stellt und deswegen auch
berichtet an den vizekanzler
was kann oder scholz tun um wladimir
putin davon abzuhalten hier ähnlich wie
in der ukraine reinzugehen eine
militärische einmischung in andere
staaten ist überhaupt nicht akzeptabel
und bricht alle regeln die wir uns
völkerrechtlich miteinander gegeben
haben und ganz besonders die regeln die
wir in europa seit dem sogenannten
kassette prozess haben und darauf müssen
wir bestehen und das von vornherein
sagen ich will aber ausdrücklich dazu
sagen dass wir eine solche reaktion auch
nicht herbeireden sollten dann im
augenblick ist ein ängstlicher präsident
der die legitimation seines volkes
verloren hat wahrscheinlich schon lange
und das ist bei diesen bei rausgekommen
dabei sich alle mögliche hilfe herbei zu
sehen die hat er noch gar nicht aber
klar muss sein dass wir nicht akzeptabel
eine einmischung putins dergleichen wäre
nicht akzeptabel sagt der vizekanzler
dass die botschaft von hier aus berlin
vor allen dingen an alex c nach minz dem
wir gute besserung wünschen ganz
herzlich wir haben gehört dass auch
versucht dort jetzt ärztliche versorgung
für ihn noch mal zu organisieren wir
haben die schweren
wunden oder male an den oberschenkeln
und den ganzen beinen gesehen also von
hier wirklich herzliche grüße alexej und
alles gute und weiterhin so so so viel
mut dort auf der straße ich glaube es
sind heute ein bisschen hoffnungsvollere
bilder die uns dort aus minsk erreicht
haben weil die mengen mittlerweile
ebenso so groß sind
danke alexej und danke dir
paul wir bleiben noch mal kurz im
ausland herr scholz
sie sind nicht der einzige der jetzt in
den wahlkampf zieht auch in den usa
steht ein großer wahlkampf an der hoch
emotionalen natürlich geführt wird
möglicherweise haben auch sie dabei die
eine oder andere emotionen
drücken sie die beiden die daumen dass
er gewinnt ja das tue ich als bürger
dieser welt und als jemand der natürlich
auch politisch für ein programm steht
das darauf gerichtet ist dass wir
vernünftig miteinander in der welt
umgehen und dass wir gleichzeitig in
unsere länder versöhnen und nicht
spalten und beides ist ja in der letzten
zeit nicht das was wir so alles gesehen
haben ist ungewöhnlicher vorgang da ist
ein mitglied der bundesregierung ist
sich so klar bekennt gegen den
amtierenden präsidenten das hat dem
herausforderer ganz stark die daumen
drückt umgekehrt würden sie es
möglicherweise als unzulässige
einmischung empfinden
ich würde mich aber nicht beschweren
finale herrscher als herzlichen dank für
den besuch wollen wir ihnen einmal ein
bisschen arbeit vielleicht abnehmen für
das nächste jahr wir haben mal ein
bisschen überlegt wie die wahlplakate
der spd mit dem kanzlerkandidaten olaf
scholz aussehen könnten haben drei
vorschläge für sie gemacht vielleicht wo
man kurz den blick darauf werfen
das wäre der erste steht bloß spd drauf
ist aber nicht drin kommt nicht in frage
nämlich an
was passt nicht der körper schon mal aus
zweiter vielleicht ist bei den dreien
was dabei vielleicht der slogan ich bin
stolz auf deutschland
nein ich bin finde das ist ein bisschen
größten waren sie nicht ich bin aber er
findet dass wir in einer guten land
leben und möchte es noch besser wird
dann hat man drittes für sie ein ganz
liebevoll getextetes
oh love you aber zuneigung gehört zur
politik dazu wer das nicht hat der ist
falsch am platz in der demokratie und
sie werden vermutlich noch keins von den
dreien direkt übernehmen
wir haben uns das noch viel aber legt
die haben sie schon nein wir haben
natürlich die plakate noch nicht
festgelegt das wäre ja völlig absurd
aber wir haben eine klare strategie ein
bisschen davon ab welcher erzählt es
geht darum dass unser land nach vorne
kommt die nächsten zehn jahre werden
eine große weichenstellung sein
es geht nicht nur um die zeit nach
corona klar und die frage ob das sozial
weitergeht oder nicht sozial
aber es geht auch um die frage wie wir
die großen entscheidungen so
voranbringen dass das ein gutes land für
alle bürger nur bürger bleibt hat sie
dank für das gespräch hier heute am
sonntagabend der vizekanzler der
finanzminister und der spd
kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz die live
bild und wir wollen einmal über das
sprechen was war dann in der letzten
knappen stunde hier live bei bild gehört
haben und das macht jetzt meine kollegin
bild chefreporterin carina meßbauer mit
einer ganz interessante karriere ja
danke die acai wir haben diesen auftritt
von olaf scholz aufmerksam verfolgt und
wollen jetzt der frage nachgehen wie
guter sich geschlagen hat wo seine
stärken und auch seine schwächen liegen
und ob er vielleicht mehr kann als
vizekanzler
das ganze möchte ich jetzt analysieren
mit eva quadbeck stellvertretende
chefredakteurin der rheinischen post
und franka lehfeld rtl journalistin
claus strunz tv-moderator und bild
chefredakteur julian reichelt
hallo frau quadbeck wir wissen's olaf
scholz ist bereits vizekanzler was
würden sie jetzt nach diesem auftritt
sagen kann er denn auch mehr kann auch
kanzler
grundsätzlich ist er jemand der
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen kann
und er hat auch in vielen ämtern
bewiesen dass er politik umsetzen kann
er selber hat ja definiert man muss
krise können man muss verantwortung
übernehmen können muss entscheidungen
treffen also diese grundlagen das
einmaleins der politik beherrscht er
natürlich
und ob er dann ein land regieren kann
das hängt sehr damit zusammen was für
partner hat und das hat man ja auch in
der sendung gesehen das ist der wunde
punkt mit wem soll er seine macht
gründen würde es für rot-grün reichen da
würde ich sagen ja ein solches bündnis
konnte scholz anführen
aber in dem moment in dem er die linken
braucht und tatsächlich regieren zu
können sieht es sehr schlecht aus weil
dann passt es überhaupt gar nicht mehr
zusammen koalition wollen wir noch mal
besprechen herrscht uns das einmaleins
der politik hat er drauf wie sehen sie
das ist klar olaf schulze sehr
erfahrener politiker
aber ich habe darüber nachgedacht
welches plakat das sind ja drei plakate
präsentiert wurden nach diesem gespräch
das richtige wäre und ich sehe in roten
wackelpudding den mann an die wand
nagelt das ist olaf scholz ein mann
voller fachkompetenz mit null charisma
eine art hausmeister der deutschen
politik so hat er auch in hamburg
politik macht und wenn deutschland das
will also so eine art fortsetzung von
angela merkel in einer männer gestalt er
ist jetzt sozusagen die männliche
version von angela merkel in all diesen
tugenden und wissens feldern und
bereichen dann hat eine wirkliche chance
wähler zu erreichen er ist finde ich
kurioserweise der perfekte spd-kandidat
und auch das verbindet ihn mit angela
merkel weil es nämlich keinen anderen
gibt der so war wie er
ich würde das gern nochmal weitergeben
die männliche version von angela merkel
sagt claus strunz wie sehen sie die
rolle fällt ist ist olaf scholz kanzler
fähig oder doch nur eine kopie der
jetzigen kanzlerin also ich würde sagen
ganz klar olaf scholz kann kanzler aber
die spd kann nicht regieren zumindest
nicht die aktuelle spd weil wir sprechen
jetzt von einem kandidaten der wie herr
strunz ja gerade ansprach bereits in
hamburg regiert hat er hat dort aber die
cdu klein gehalten indem er sich
eigentlich rechts von ihr positioniert
hat mit wirtschaft mit finanzpolitik
geworben und überzeugt hat das sind
seine stärken und deshalb ja olaf scholz
kann kanzler aber wo ist die partei die
das mitträgt wir haben es gehört wir uns
aber lebt heute dem gerade auch im
beitrag gehört norbert walter borjans
hat sich geäußert und das war ein
ähnlicher spagat wegen jetzt macht er
weiter bei uns muss jetzt die linke
politik verteilt
und herr scholz eigentlich seine
erfahrungen und das was seiner
vergangenheit getan hat und ich glaube
das ist ein spagat
ob der dieses jahr übersteht das wird
die zentrale frage sein ich möchte in
der runde gleich nochmal die
koalitionsoptionen besprechen aber
julian erst mal an dich die frage wie
bewertest du diesen auftritt und nach
diesem auftritt was sagst du würde er in
einem eventuellen duell gegen söderling
und co bestehen können ja in der
politischen landschaft die an die wir
uns gewöhnt haben um den letzten jahren
in deutschland in der langeweile trumpf
ist könnte er mit sicherheit ein duell
gegen markus söder bestehen das
aufregende an dem gespräch wenn man das
wort auf regelt hier mal verwenden darf
fand nicht eigentlich dass olaf scholz
interessanteste punkte seine stärksten
punkte mit den möglichen koalitionen die
für ihn in frage kommen eigentlich nicht
vereinbar sind also das wasser
außenpolitisch gesagt hat was
lukaschenka angeht zum beispiel das war
das war sehr viel war für vernünftige
menschen fand ich einziges problem ist
er würde dafür keine koalition finden
weil in der linkspartei liebe sie alles
was östlich von uns ist besonders das
was im kreml sitzt und was von dort aus
geht also oder scholz hat heute abend
einige gute punkte gesagt für die er
sich dann aber leider eine koalition
suchen müsste dies nach derzeitiger
analyse nicht aktuell in den umfragen
ist ja nur söder beliebter als olaf
scholz was würden sie sagen wenn muss
jetzt quasi selber antreten für die
union um den kanzler scholz zu
verhindern
in der union ist das überhaupt noch
nicht gemeldet wer das werden könnte
also das rennen ist ja auch relativ
knapp sparen hat in den umfragewerten ja
auch erheblich zugelegt
die union muss jetzt tatsächlich das was
die spd vorgelegt hat nach ziehen
nämlich geschlossenheit zeigen sich
hinter einem zu versammeln und dann ist
es im direkten kampf gegen scholz gar
nicht so ganz wichtig ob dieser mann
jetzt söder laschet oder sparen oder
auch mehr zeit das würde ich gern noch
mal weitergeben wie sehen sie es ist das
nicht so wichtig wer für die union
antritt
naja also
wenn man jetzt punktuell sich das
anguckt hätte ja nur microsoft eine
wirkliche chance kanzler werden zu
können
der wahlkampf süder gegen scholz wäre
einer auf den man schon guckt aber
achtung auch markus söder tendiert wenn
es darum geht sehr stark zum ausgleichen
und zum außerdem rangeln sie sich um den
gleichen koalitionspartner wenn ich
alles richtig sehe nämlich um die grünen
und ich will noch mal eins ergänzen weil
jetzt alle von scholz zu sagen also der
hat da bewegung rein gebracht denn die
spd und sind von 15 auf 18 prozent
gestiegen
also er hat im grunde die partei aus dem
sterbehospiz zurück in die
intensivstation gebracht in dieser woche
das ist das was passiert ist und woher
wohin sie sich entwickelt aus der
intensivstation
das muss jetzt muss sich jetzt zeigen
und ich weiß gar nicht ob die sich
wirklich hinter dem man versammelt haben
sie sagen jetzt dass sie sich hinter dem
man versammelt haben weil sie glauben
das ist ein geniestreich ist dass er die
mitte bindet wohingegen die beiden
glücklosen parteivorsitzenden er das
linke lager bin und dieser spagat das
wort gefällt mir also ich glaub auch
nach dem interview kann olaf scholz nur
mit ganz ganz ganz ganz brutalen
schmerzen in den inneren oberschenkeln
daraus humpeln weil in der spagat jetzt
schon weh tut und er wird ihn
möglicherweise zerreißen ich würde ein
punkt daraus gerne nochmal aufgreifen
und weitergeben 3% plus zurück in die
intensivstation wie sehen sie es ist das
jetzt her ein sehr moderater anstieg
oder mit wumms beziehungsweise will man
denn überhaupt jetzt ein plus 10% wie
damals bei schulz der dann aber
irgendwie in einem total crash endet
also ich würde sagen die kampagne von
olaf scholz ist heute eigentlich schon
weitgehend ausgereizt weil die zentrale
frage ist er muss wähler gewinnen
er sagte gerade zurückgewinnen und neu
gewinnen und wenn wir das
herunterbrechen
dieses wort charisma oder auch aufbruch
das hat er gerade nicht verkörpert und
ich frage mich die jungen wähler die die
jetzt auch gerade bei den grünen sind
sich dort versammeln ich sag mal
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
vielleicht dynamisch sexy neu modern
finden welches angebot
macht scholz den konkret und dann noch
ein ganz wichtiger punkt ich frage mich
in der gesamten debatte immer wo ist
eigentlich kevin kühnert mit den jusos
um die jungen leute anzusprechen gezielt
sie zurückzugewinnen und ihr also ein
angebot zu machen zu sagen die spd ist
eure partei das noch mal weitergegeben
die anderen sind möglicherweise jung
dynamisch modern was hat scholz zu
bieten könnte er in einem duell gegen
habeck oder berbalk form als sieger vom
platz gehen julian das ist etwas was man
heute interessanterweise gemerkt hat der
spd es in den letzten jahren total
dieser kampfgeist abhandengekommen
überhaupt als sieger vom platz gehen zu
wollen hat gesagt ja wenn man zweiter
ist aber die grünen und zu sagen wir
wollen stärkste partei werden natürlich
das würde auch irgendwie absurd klingen
wenn die spd das moment sagen würde mit
15 prozent mit 18 prozent mit dem hospiz
wir werten wie claus strunz das eben
gesagt hat aber dieser diese dieser
unbedingte wille zur macht ja das was
man bei gerd schröder dass ich will hier
rein genannt hat das rütteln am tor des
kanzleramts das symbolische das ist halt
in keiner weise mehr spürbar dass es den
sozialdemokraten in den letzten jahren
wirklich durch wahlen niederlage nach
wahlniederlagen nachwahlen in der lage
einfach ausgetrieben worden ich glaube
dass es sind ganz ganz ganz
entscheidender punkt in einem wahlkampf
wie sehr willig bundeskanzler werken das
ist das worum es in wahrheit geht das
ist das worum es wenn man den
parteinamen spd trägt immer gehen muss
auch wenn das ergebnis im moment das ist
das braucht die leute schauen will da
jemand bundeskanzler werden und die
politik die die lektion aus der
geschichte der politik ist einfach wenn
ich selber nicht will wird kein anderer
für mich wollen und ich glaube die spd
muss erstmal wieder lernen selber ins
kanzleramt zu wollen und zwar nicht zu
besuch als vize-kanzler bei angela
merkel sondern im chefsessel will die
spd sie will er ist mit haut und haaren
also dahinter also ich es ist vollkommen
richtig dass die spd natürlich jetzt
nicht eine einheitliche partei ist wo es
keine differenzen mehr gibt und die
werden sicherlich auch aufbrechen wieder
in dem moment wo sie macht bekommt ich
wäre aber doch sehr zuversichtlich dass
es dieser partei gelingt das im
wahlkampf jetzt durch
also dass sich der kühnert obwohl er
nicht zu den engsten zirkel gehörte die
eingeweiht waren werden nun
kanzlerkandidat werden soll
trotzdem hat er sich am tag danach
hingestellt und hat sich komplett eben
hinter olaf scholz gestellt und auch die
differenzen die es gibt die werden im
moment ja sehr geschickt austariert die
werden nicht nach außen getragen
und da spricht schon sehr vieles dafür
dass die spd ein rationalisierungs schub
bekommen hat bisher haben die sich ja
immer gerne auf offener bühne gestritten
sehr emotional und jetzt sind sie
plötzlich eine partei die vor allen
dingen an die macht will unter der
rational ran geht indem man dann eben
auch ein juso chef sagt ich stelle mich
hinter den kanzlerkandidaten und dem in
dem eine linke partei führung sagt ja
wir nehmen diesen eher konservativen
kanzlerkandidat und der wiederum
konzessionen an die linken macht also
das darf man nicht unterschätzen eine
spd hat möglicherweise vernunft etwas
mehr einkehr gehalten aber erreicht der
kampfgeist
ich glaube dass wir jetzt hier auch den
fehler machen wie oft in politischen
debatten und ganz fein ziseliert
diskutieren und politik fällt dadurch
gehen usw
die wahrheit ist durch die spd braucht
eigentlich niemand im land wer ist
richtig links haben will der hat die
linkspartei
da kann man dann die manager abkassieren
und vermögenssteuer einführen usw
wer es mit ich bürgerlich will der hat
genug alternativen die grünen zum
beispiel die dann jetzt erschrecken gott
wir sind ja auch noch links nähe
die sind inzwischen ja zumindest in den
großstädten stand bürgerlich dann gibt
es die unionsparteien dann gibt es die
fdp
und wer es sozusagen einen blick von
ganz rechts und aus ganz unangenehmen
blickwinkel auf die welt hat der kann
dann noch weiter rechts sein kreuzchen
waren die spd obst die habe ich ganz
vergessen sie ist vollkommen eigentlich
überflüssig und träumt bei 34% und
träumt von 30% und jetzt muss natürlich
ein kanzlerkandidat ein feuer entfachen
und klar machen warum man diese partei
und ihnen überhaupt noch brauchen hat
das feuer entfacht na ja ich will jetzt
an der stelle aber auch mal sagen das
muss ja nur heute abend ich machen
also es ist zwar das erste interview
dass er in der ausführlichkeit gibt das
ist schon ein forum wo man zeigen kann
wie man ist das hat er ja also da ist
auch nicht mehr feuer
ich weiß nicht ob sie alle waren ja
gesehen haben wir da bei seiner
vorstellung war da war ich ja dankbar
dass überhaupt noch reden darf nachdem
die beiden parteivorsitzenden
stundenlang irgendwas erzählt haben wie
man so dämlich in wahlkampf beginnen
kann und nicht reinkommen sagt wir haben
eine tolle entscheidung getroffen und
dann spricht der kandidat und pustet
schon mal die leute im raum weg die da
sitzen die journalisten und die sagen na
was ist jetzt sinnlos jetzt beginnt
etwas neues das ist die verwaltung der
vergangenheit mit einem gesicht aus der
vergangenheit und gegenwart und gaukelt
vor die die die ordnung und den sinn und
die logik der zukunft zu verkaufen sei
dies gerade beschrieben hat ja auch der
schulz wahlkampf begonnen und was kam
raus nicht besonders viel aber das
langsam und nicht unbedingt nur in
schulzes und das lager der spd aber da
kann man vielleicht auch die wähler so
ein bisschen unterschätzen wenn man oder
falsch einschätzen wenn man glaubt dass
die wirklich lust schonen wollen ich
glaube dass in einem punkt habe sonst
sonst hätten wir ja nicht 16 jahre
merkel gab ich glaube dass sie da an
starken punkt haben ich habe darüber
nachgedacht es könnte sein dass olaf
scholz diesen historischen sagt man
nicht window of opportunity also das
fenster des die gelegenheit jetzt die
gelegenheit sogar dass er genau jetzt
der richtige spd mann ist genau jetzt
und wenn corona sich wieder gelegt hat
und wenn herr luca schenkung von mir aus
irgendwie geschichte ist dann geht das
fenster auch wieder zu kleines problem
die wahl ist erst nächstes jahr er hat
von ausgesprochen offenbar zumindest
hier in der runde ja relativ einig hat
man es ihnen nicht allzu sehr an gemerkt
ich würde trotzdem einmal kurz eine
schnelle runde machen 30 prozent wie
realistisch ist das rollfeld
ich gestehe mehr als 25 und das halte
ich schon für sehr optimistisch traue
ich der spd auch mit olaf scholz nicht
zu wenn man ihnen etwas mehr
kampfeswillen noch anmerken wird was ist
dann drin für spd ich frage mich also
19,5 lange gesichter wieder irgendwelche
hässliche 9,5 also unter 20 also 30
prozent unreal sind unrealistisch so
beschluss können sich die anderen nicht
anstellen julian was glaubst du hast für
die spd drin
also ich prophezeie ein wahlergebnis was
den gesicht von ralf stegner alle ehre
machen wird und ich habe fast das gefühl
diese 30 prozent prognose ist schon der
erste stock den man ihm da zwischen die
beine wirft das wird er jetzt im
interview mit sich rumschleppt und wird
immer sagen wenn er sagt ja 30 prozent
schaffe ich sagen alle das verrückt
geworden und wenn er seit 30 prozent
sukzessiv sagen alle der hat keinen bis
also das schon aus meiner sicht das
erste quer treiben genauso wie man es
aus der spd gegenüber ihren vorsitzenden
seit jahrzehnten gewohnt ist vielleicht
noch mal zur geschlossenheit weil ja
also alle so berauscht sind wir
geschlossen die spd es ist das ist doch
schon nicht sachse 12 und die uhrzeit
deutlich der text sauerei ich bin der
kanzlerkandidat und sage 20 prozent
schaffen wir dann kommt mein portal
vorsitzender und sagt 30 also hinter
ford sicher vor führender nicht
gemeinsam geht es ja gar nicht dass wir
den sport passiert dass der
vereins-präsident ein anderes ergebnis
nennt als der trainer oder der trainer
ein anderes ziel als der spieler ist es
der ausweis für totalen telepathisch
muss oder aber für ein nicht
koordiniertes vorgehen was in der
politik das gleiche ist wie glaubwürdig
halten sie jetzt diese neue
geschlossenheit in der spd und wie lange
wird sie anhalten
ich habe ja ein gehen schon gesagt dass
ich eben nicht daran glaube dass das
jetzt in den nächsten monaten so
einwandfrei funktionieren wird aber eins
muss man fällt an dieser stelle sagen
der parteivorsitzende hat ja nicht
gesagt olaf scholz muss die 30 prozent
knapp ja nur gesagt wie es eher auf
seine eingehende prognose gekommen hat
den weg erklärt heute wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe hat gesagt es
gibt in der bevölkerung die bereitschaft
die spd zu wählen oder die heimat vieler
wähler und er glaubt die muss man wieder
motivieren trotzdem was ich auch noch
sagen wollte ich bin da bei herrscht und
ich glaube die kommende wahl ist eben um
es mal herunter zu brechen auch die
frage aufbruch schwung neuer also auch
mit blick auf herrn söder auf die grünen
oder eben dieses merkel erbe wie sie
eingehend sagen weiter so konstant und
das hängt mit sicherheit auch von dem
faktor ab wo stehen wir denn in dieser
zeit wie weit wie
mit der korona krise weiter gestritten
also da sind einige unbekannte die wir
heute noch gar nicht einschätzen können
ich würde diesen punkt gern nochmal
aufgreifen und dann sehen weitergeben
und die frage stellen möglicherweise
vielleicht ja auch ein plus das scholz
als eine art amtsinhaber bonus ins rennt
also mit einem art amtsinhaber bonus ins
rennen geht weil wir jetzt zum ersten
mal seit langem dem fall haben dass die
kanzlerin oder der der amtsinhaber eben
nicht mehr kandidiert ist das auch
möglich oder klebt er so dieses merkel
erbe an an ihm negativ das ist auf jeden
fall teil der strategie der spd dass sie
sagen wir haben hier den vizekanzler und
auch versuchen diesen amtsbonus
auszunutzen und nun muss man sagen je
beliebter die kanzlerin wieder geworden
ist desto größer sind natürlich auch die
chancen für einen typus wenn auch ein
typus mann davon ein bisschen feenstaub
abzubekommen und das im wahlkampf eben
auch noch für sich zu nutzen
ich würde gern noch eine schnelle
abschlussrunde machen und bei ihnen
anfangen was wünschen sie olaf scholz
für den wahlkampf guten achten und vor
allem klarheit ich würde ihm raten sich
festzulegen seinen wählern wir haben es
gerade auch gehört in ihren anfragen
wähler zuschauer
ich glaube die strategie zurück zur
volkspartei damit dass man einfach alle
ins boot zieht und alle vereint und heim
decke ich glaube das funktioniert nicht
ich würde für klarheit sorgen und dann
ist natürlich die frage ob das team spd
so wie wir es jetzt heute abend
analysiert hat herr strunz ihr ihre
wünsche für urlaubs für den nächsten 13
monate in super fitness coach der ihm
die schmerzen beim spagat reck machte
beinfreiheit von seiner partei und
julian du hast das schlusswort ja ich
wünsche mir vor allem volle kassen denn
auch wenn das abgestritten hat die
wähler bis zur wahl zu bezahlen ist die
economy stupid ist schon so ziemlich mit
das hoffnungsvolle mittel was es gibt
aber als hamburger und landsmann wünsche
ich ihm tatsächlich toll toll toll denn
ich glaube aus tiefer überzeugung dass
deutschland eine deutlich stärkere spd
braucht als solche und das im moment hat
damit vielen dank hier an die runde das
waren die richtigen fragen sonntagabend
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]